recently a subscriber put something in
my video saying that I curse too much so
um what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
dedicate this month to not cursing at
all the shit's that's not it got that
mother Oh what is going on YouTube
recently a subscriber asked how do i
freak it with my boyfriend I don't want
to hurt him a word you don't want to
hurt somebody you're about to destroy
this is dumbest thing I've ever heard
mmm I feel that nobody knows how to
break up with people nowadays because
everybody loves to give stupid advice
now I'm out of here no right moment to
break up with somebody you just got to
do it like Reba listen it's not you [ __ ]
so y'all damn damn don't give me hope
you don't break up with me you're like a
bandit yeah well anybody who says
ripping a band-aid off isn't painful is
either a liar or a thug
hey y'all ever seen a third trying to
stop himself in crying just like the
funniest thing on earth don't you do it
good see walk it up if you walk it off
every girl loves a pal do these type of
reasons that still have us thinking we
buy our chance it's just the wrong place
at the wrong time
I just want to be single for now I want
to spread my wings go say stuff like
that because despite what you say this
is what we hear go out the light and
just put me out on misery and do it to
me quick because I that's what she said
I don't want to hear all the back
stories about why it happened just send
it to me in the email when you tell it
do that there is still a chance somehow
do you know what you're gonna turn them
into I'll stop even though you dumped my
and technically we're broken up I still
consider us together because you said we
still you know we got a chance so um
that's your fault a copy over you print
out pictures on your face touching
myself oh did that Joey went too far I'm
telling you straight up what you do be
on your facebook you'd be like what is
this about the messy
turn are you [ __ ] him it's not you
it's me
let's look you and I both know that
don't mean jack [ __ ] look I'll get it
okay wait you're not sexually attracted
me anymore you know titty [ __ ] go both
ways at this point you get a stop trying
to look for a way to spare my feelings
because you're breaking up with me it's
too late for that and i'ma go home this
is a brightman night so Whitney used in
each of Twinkies and cuss myself to like
the [ __ ] just be honest when you break
up with somebody you're not really
helping them out by telling them that
you're the problem no matter who you
played or who you want to place it on
this is what's gonna happen I'll be at
the gym tomorrow I'm losing weight I'm
putting on after this double
cheeseburger though it is by far the
worst breaker glad you could use in the
history of break up lines just be
straight up like a [ __ ] and break up
with me because either way I'm gonna be
hurt but no picture not me with all this
little boo-boo garble and she's that
word Google darlin look I know if I fall
I'm in it
copy while watching Cambodian [ __ ]
porn way too many times no say that we
can still be friends right after we just
broke up and I can still be friends
after you just don't move on and be with
somebody else
let the chop your titties off would be
friends let me tell you something I
would never say this [ __ ] to your face
but I hope you just be by yourself for
the rest of your life case you didn't
know boo boo once you lose this you
can't have none of them today you want
to be best friends immediately after a
relationship is over it's basically
saying you want to feel good about the
break-up but still move on to somebody
else
hey why you got to feel good about I
feel like [ __ ] she'll smile better look
like this that's about it you wanna
break up with somebody don't pussyfoot
around and just do open by the way nor
for me to get over you I have to hate
you for a bit just to convince myself
that you're not right for me so don't
worry about it my feels girl without her
hate your [ __ ] guts
wish I'd rather fall off and attach it
upper lip so you have a mustache [ __ ]
[ __ ] it
right there and everybody else seto here
we go